bonjour jean marie jean marie g 20
unique de beurre doux de de cheyrou
c'est bien c'est d'une miss aisne de
mycènes ravin sur ce qu'il me faut elle
va tu mets une ville combien ces bases
18 5 ans et corail voilà merci jean
marie voilà jean marie ben ali at-on
merci à marie
[Musique]
hu
bonjour pierre bonjour j'ai dit
aujourd'hui vous nous proposez une
entrée oui une entrée les cagouilles à
la charentaise
ok ce que c'est ça les cagouilles c'est
aussi les humeurs c'est quoi du mal à
lui masser les petits gris c'est ça les
cagous il est d'humeur aux charentes
voilà celle ci c'est pour rendre hommage
à la ville d'angoulême parce qu'on a
quand même eu un prix le prix là
gastronomades est donc en remerciement
va faire une recette des chats très bien
alors je mets mon tablier cagouille
voilà alors les ingrédients nous faudra
six douzaines de petits gris pour 4
personnes un demi litre de vin blanc 8
gousses d'ail 16 petits oignons grelots
qu'est ce que c'est que des oignons
grelots c'est une petits oignons blancs
comme on fait des oignons vinaigre voilà
seize petits oignons grelots
avec un peu de vinaigre pour les
éplucher j'expliquerai pourquoi un gros
poireau 150 g de lardons fumés ou salé
selon ce que vous trouvez deux tomates
80 g de beurre des charentes évidemment
on va profiter de la charente une
cuillère de chats plus une demi botte de
persil du sel et du poivre et on a tout
pour faire nos kaguya la charentaise
alors on va commencer tout de suite par
s'occuper de cibler nos poireau je
continue mes poils l'oignon alors un
petit truc tous impôts pas pleurer
madame c'est ce que vous faite puisque
déjà plus les oignons
j'ai mis de l'eau chaude et je me plonge
je mets un peu de vinaigre plonge mes
oignons dedans comme ça la pause ramolli
et si on épluche en principe on pleure
pas disons qu'on pleure moins bon et ben
jusqu'ici ça a été alors on va
simplement ciseler le poireau alors les
petits oignons alors c'est la charente
essayé de bien faire ce n'est ce pas bon
comme chez qu'on les regarde élabore si
elle est petite erreur vous préférez
vous écrivez n'est ce pas on va
s'appliquer que ça va aller voilà les
petits oignons il va et éplucher donc à
peu près cette petite année
obligé que ce soit des petits gros lot
ah oui les petits creux à l'eau comme sa
plus jolie
c'est plus joli donc je vais mettre ma
poil tranquillement à chauffer pendant
qu'on travaille je peux pas perdre de
temps je vais mettre 70 à 80 g de beurre
des charentes évidemment j'aime faire
mon âme hacher grossièrement apte à lire
comme ça voilà comme ça un achat si vous
avez un petit prince aille à la maison
évidemment je vais prendre votre petit
pré saint génis oui donc j'ai misé
oignons j'habite au match des mets toi
roger tout pour être heureux je vais
faire simplement revenir un peu mais
lardons dans mon bird et qui sera bien
chaud voilà dès qu'il a moussé un petit
peu bien chaud mais à la limite de la
coloration nous mettons nous là bas j'ai
jamais mangé samoa alors on est habitués
nous endort ça paraît incroyable à
manger escargots de bourgogne à la
provende mal mais là ça va nous changer
un peu il ya de la iusy à des légumes
on dirait bien tokpa pot-au-feu même si
une potée avaient été votés ou aux
escargots et aux légumes ou alors on va
prendre un peu de coloration et ça le
plus l'arbre c'est une grande spécialité
des charentais oui le beurre commence à
collombey et bien chaud je veux mettre
mes poireaux émincés
donc on veut aussi du verre voilà vert
et blanc oui j'oublié précisé on va
laisser prendre une légère coloration on
va ajouter ça commence à colorer
légèrement ajouté nos petits oignons
madame que les maires alors à peu près 4
par personne
mes oignons grelots on finira par là
après on ajoutera de te mettre concassé
au génie regardes et tu attrapes de
jeunes belles petites couleurs bon alors
empêché avec la spatule
les grands chefs à ont fait sauter
évident non à la main un tournant mais
par amour on est content mais voilà mais
sinon on fait avec votre spatule
mais j'aime bien alors on va mettre
notre petite taille
concassez grossièrement envoyée alors
j'ai mis huit gousses d'ail face il faut
qu'on est sale goût faut relever des
gemmes elle ajouté maintenant m alors on
peut là les vues on peut les relevés la
faute au sol
moi je vais cela pose c'est un plat
campagne r1 janvier les goûts vrai
rebond et c'est à ce moment là je vais
mettre du poivre et du sel
il ya encore une jolie connaissent et
toutes ses couleurs et le poivre ail
électroniques et des brevets est pour sa
part en italie bellemare oui et on va
mettre un peu de sel fin
oui c'est du theil cinq belles couleurs
oui il sera toujours des poils enfantin
ah ouais j'en bave pas l'enfant dont
on va le laisser simplement coloré
encore une ou deux minutes et on va
ajouter le vin blanc
alors elle me dit toujours pareil
m'apprendre durable en tout ca du vin
blanc ordinaire quoi apple de prendre
des grands vins blancs et je vais
mouiller avec à peu près un demi litre
vin blanc et pour enlever un peu la cité
vin blanc parce que c'est quand même
assez à steve on va mouiller avec de
l'eau mais sa chère martine
comme ça de l'eau alors on met un peu
d'eau fait pas une question d'économie
est ce que ben comme investi j'ai dit ça
commence à bouillir à gros bouillons on
va donc simplement réduire un peu notre
gaz pour ça me choque tout doucement
pendant une vingtaine de minutes génie
on va s'occuper de mettre nos cagouille
dans notre bouillon qui a vingt minutes
que ça cuit les petits oignons ail
servir tous sont dans voilà confondant
donc c'est le moment de les mettre les
escargots ou la vache thématique vie
voilà je les ai pris en boîte mais on
peut les faire soi même les prendre dans
le jardin et 5 du laurier des clous de
girofle bref c'est très long là je les
ai pris en boîte il faut avouer que son
très bon bien les rincer à l'eau froide
1 passe quelque chose vous devez donc
j'ai mis 2 x 18 tigi et 72 pour quatre
personnes
c'est pas mal quand même hein comme
portions comme chez les multis noulens
prendre 12 des gros la télévision a mis
18 et on va laisser mijoter ça pendant
cinq six minutes
maintenant il faut que nous le cagou y
attrape le good ses légumes et où on va
laisser jeu pire ça pendant quatre cinq
minutes à laissac six minutes même à
lyon n'est pas une minute près ça c'est
encore une bonne recette
on y voit là une bonne retraite ou des
amateurs mais il ya beaucoup de gens qui
sont très heureux d'avoir des recettes
mais ils se disent on aimerait bien en
avoir plusieurs à la fois et il n'y a
pas moyen d'avoir un quelque chose de
plus à dire c'est vrai nous disent qu'on
va trop vite ils ont pris le temps
d'écrire donc gens qu'à écrire à france
3 vers la liberté
mais mon petit patrick villechaize et
moi même nous sommes en train de refaire
un livre ou qui aura presque tout notre
seb donc le livre arriver bientôt
mesdames vous pourrez vous régalez vous
aurez tous les recettes près un livre
pratique pour mettre dans votre cuisine
à sa légende le réclame et déjà depuis
longtemps c'est bien ça arrive ça fait
cinq six minutes que ça mijote on va
goûter pour voir si c'est assez salée h
f vous voulez passer une cuillère s'il
vous plaît chochotte
je ne tente brûlé on va remettre un
petit peu de preuve peut-être bien voilà
je crois que ce sera parfait ha oui pal
et du froid alors on fini on va prendre
du persil d'à peu près l'équivalent
d'une demi bottes ne la chapelure
l'équivalent d'une cuillère à peu près
on va mettre simplement un peu de
chapelure ce sera simplement pour lier
un peu la sauce oui dans le fond ça fait
office de farine
voilà ça fait un peut le faire si elle
commet dans les cuisses de grenouilles
et maintenant on va sous poudre et lens
en a les couleurs c'est un vrai tableau
un fils quand on sait les cuisses de
grenouilles ont fini en queue de
chapelure du persil et le moins très
agréable donc on va mélanger maintenant
légèrement et ça va dire ah oui même
veut goûter la sauce
ben on a pu cadrer ses on va prendre les
assiettes mme hadad
un petit pas qu'on a mis au chaud alors
je le prends au mais à peu près 18
cagouille par personne à peu près alors
qu'un tognon laisser le respecté ce
qu'on a mis en signer un peu plus nous
c'est pas grave
non on ne mangera mais comment j'admire
vous avez des mains en faire ça bien
chaud msf à bouilland bouillant mais
c'est bon quand même
et bah non kaguya la charentaise mais
voilà presse qu'au pays la charente
alors nous vous la partie recette cargo
on va découvrir une spécialité de la
charente pour moi j'ai jamais goûté et
ben génie goûtez moi ça
avec plaisir
[Musique]
parce que
et 18 comme c'est un petit gris
abattement de révolte ou alors je vais
prendre un petit bourgogne aligoté
bourgogne aligoté john bale pourrait
très bien
[Musique]